oh I came to this video playing boo pre
put a bill pryor from from the USA I
guess yeah I mean I know how this United
States flag looks like but you sometimes
have those flags that are rather similar
with only slight differences and the
stars or something ok so the Catalan are
playing them the clothes variation for a
change them while ago I'm had a look at
this line that's it's not so bad let's
just test his ambition here Bishop f4 of
course I wouldn't draw then with the
just repeating but it's always school
sometimes interesting to test what the
other sizes is intending ok b6 Bishop
basics this is one idea of this closed
closter setup hmm can i play b5 here
maybe be five
yeah usually white answers b5 will see 5
but here i have before Andy to hangs
oops okay I think you should have played
differently snow looks fairly fairly
unconvincing so I wanna pawn but not the
game still need to play play well I'd
like to play if I've this would be very
helpful and he also might play a
three-game I want to play Bishop da to
Bishop d8 to c7 nice rather quick with
the attacking fi but if he goes rook a
one i have e five so he might he attacks
a five now it but he lost control over a
five so on this looks nice are
interesting but i can i can at least I
can take deform I can play for him yeah
but ok let's let's grab this sir a good
porn
95 or or something else now to e5 it has
the nice additional idea that after a
possible night d3i have 90 °c for this
is Sir this is nice okay can he somehow
attack it do you form not so easy okay I
need to move this bishop and connect
rooks he's got the apron which is so
which is still a factor in this game of
course came
mmm Knight to c4 I would be really nice
but Queenie 6 is just not great i can i
can do here this is good i can i can go
to you form you cannot take twice
because h3 is no hanging at least I mean
taketake Nazi for us also good okay
analysis looks nice this night night g6
I could go to the seven yeah why not t7
attack it's e5 in twice the female now
place night d three outs have Knight to
c3 which is quite cute rookie to amongst
others all night be five at the right
moment might be fire it's not not really
not really improving my position maybe
this one just if I can exchange it then
Queenie 7 and take c 5s on
can also check him
rook to be some
complicated
human I'd be five is probably not so
great and a playing far too slowly
you can I think just take it
wow what I thought you could just take
it steady yourself okay don't have much
choice here grab a headline no not
really yeah down long time but Sam it's
a bit bit bit too much too much edge
i blundered t5 check DRA offered no time
warning
I can I think I can really rather
comfortably go for a draw if I want
check
check-check
no okay and it didn't work out cause of
the time yeah a shame game Gran I think
I got close to winning here it's a bit
unlucky that term that I couldn't cover
age five it's just a matter of a bit of
precision here because I get to the f
porn track so somewhere somewhere here
where Luke beard the ROP a time okay i
didn't i didn't have edited at eleven
seconds i only need to prevent him from
attacking age five he cannot play the F
porn and I'm just going here and at the
end attack f2 so it's a it's a win oh
yeah okay here I shouldn't blunder the
two points but 36 seconds check all
right thanks for watching